hello my name is Katelyn minutes and I
am David Titsworth we are presenting
particular chart IQ later is a highly
interactive web-based application that
allows you to create custom chart
layouts traditional tools force you to
use a predefined set of charts or
require coding to pull off the layouts
that you actually want it articulator
does not have this problem it allows you
to create an infinite number of chart
layouts with relative ease so I'm gonna
kick it over to Kate to show some
examples of some charts that can be made
which articulator we were going to be
creating one these charts called the
Boston weather data set in this data set
has the temperatures for a day for
Boston now she added a data axis and now
she's binding some of the columns some
of the columns to her date axis she
added a line mark which will add a line
for each row in the data set and then
she applied a polar scaffold so that it
would arrange in a circular fashion
she's now gonna bind the the color of
the line to a stroke gradient or a color
gradient to make it look more
temperature II now she's gonna add a
circle which will represent the
precipitation of a given day and now
she's binding the size of the circle to
precipitation and then scaling it up a
little bit so we see it a little bit
better now she's going to change it to
kind of a watery color and turn down the
opacity a little bit so that the
temperatures still still show through
she's gonna do it just the margins on
the visual itself so that it looks just
a little bit better she's going to
adjust the title to be in the center of
the visual and then rename it
now she's gotta just the font of the
title and then make it a little bit less
a little bit less dark so it blends in a
little bit better she's also going to do
the same thing with the data access make
it blend in just a little bit better
finally she's going to adjust the
margins on the visual so that fits the
entire chart width and here we have a
final visual to articulated cut
particular is available on particular
data articulator comm we hope it
revolutionizes the way you go about
creating charts and the story and
storytelling thank you